[Music]
maturities are very large they're one of
the largest animals in the ocean
certainly they're the largest of any of
the ray species
they can get up to about 25 feet across
when they come towards you and they're
that size they look like an alien
spacecraft as they go overhead
they actually blight out the sun
it's just so incredible to be that close
to such a large animal especially one
that you don't have to fear
[Music]
my name's andrea marshall i'm a manta
ray researcher and a marine biologist
i've been in love with the ocean all of
my life ever since i could remember i
wanted to be a marine biologist
when i moved out to africa with the
intention of studying things like great
white sharks
i actually shifted my focus over to
manta rays when i realized that no one
had ever done a study on mantras before
[Music]
one of the things that makes mantra so
special is that they're large and
sometimes people feel frightened by them
just because of their sheer size but
actually they're one of the most gentle
animals in the entire ocean
[Music]
manta rays are a very intelligent animal
they actually have the largest brain of
any marine fish but one of the things
that surprises me the most is just the
fact that they seek out encounters with
humans so this is an animal that swims
away from you this is an animal that
swims to you
they recognize you almost as a friend
[Music]
so
southern mozambique is just an
incredible location
i've lived here for the last 15 years
and even though i travel all over the
world to do my work i enjoy coming back
here because this is such a wild place
it's so exciting
[Music]
one of the reasons i began work on
mantas is because i knew that these
animals were under threat recently you
know within the last 15 to 20 years they
have started to be fished for asian
tonics
and as a result of this we've seen manta
populations crashing across the globe
even here in mozambique where we don't
even have a very aggressive fishery
we've seen the population collapse by up
to about 98 over the last 15 years
we're starting to to lose them faster
than we can study them so it's really
important for me to get these messages
across to people who don't have the
opportunity to peek down into the
underwater world
[Music]
on eli malk island in palau there is a
lake like no other
[Music]
the saltwater lake was once connected to
the ocean but as the island changed it
was closed off
now in isolation it is filled with a
jellyfish species found nowhere else
the golden jellyfish
these cryptic creatures spend their days
migrating across the lake from one side
to the other following the path of the
sun which feeds the fast-growing algae
that this jellyfish species feeds on
and with no predators to keep them in
check the jellyfish swarm and fill the
lake like a cloudy dream
it's safe for humans to swim in because
though these jellyfish do have stingers
they are too small to be felt by humans
gliding through this place feels
otherworldly
[Music]
[Music]
they're huge
you know it's like seeing a bus in the
water
and she looks at you with those big eyes
and she stares at you it feels beautiful
that's when you know that she's letting
you in
that's anwar pathani
he's a photographer
and in 2015 he won the grand prize in
national
traveler photo contest for his photo
whale whisperer
so we're talking about what it feels
like to come face to face with one of
the largest mammals on our planet
the first time it was in roca partida we
knew we were going to see the whales
because we were hearing them
and when they're nearby your whole body
resonates so strong
oh i love the sound of the whales it's
it's as beautiful as seeing them
he's underwater and off in the distance
i saw the silhouette of the whale
big big sure that looks like a submarine
without features it's just like a big
object and as he got closer things
became clearer oh there's the eye
there's the theme
that's a big wheel
it's a very big wheel
the most profound feeling he had was a
connection to the whale herself
she looks at you right into your eyes
yeah
and you feel the connection now there's
a mammal connection
you feel accepted
anwar has been diving for 17 years and
his photographs are more than just
pictures most of the photos i make i try
to share them because people that
doesn't dive and doesn't know the ocean
they might start to pay attention to the
ocean
and i like wales
it's a reminder
that we share the world with
very very wise and beautiful animals
down there
[Music]
no matter how many the middle aspect
always so much harder and when you're
swimming six to ten hours by yourself
i started running out of things to think
about
your mind starts getting exhausted
my name is chris frame and i swam the
entire length of the mississippi river
it took me 181 days
[Music]
the mississippi river is two thousand
three hundred and twenty miles long
beginning in minnesota it empties into
the gulf of mexico
and in 2015 chris rank took it on to
raise awareness and honor gold star
families
the gold star family is a family that's
lost a loved one in service to our
country so it's just really inspiring so
i was like i i want to do
something
so he took on the mighty mississippi
it's an amazing powerful river so you
don't really know what to expect
we did as much research as possible into
what you'll face in the mississippi
you see a lot of wildlife out there
you'll see bald eagles flying around a
lot of alligators stuff like that
one thing that i was really kind of
surprised about was how big the swells
get in the river you know i didn't
expect 10 plus foot swells
the only time that i would not swim
was when there was a fog so if there's
storms still swimming through the storms
you know we did hit some pretty big
storms going down the river one storm he
remembers in particular we're making
good time and before you know it the sky
is just pitch black it's just sideways
rain winds changing constant direction
the lightning's flashing around and
you can feel it it's hidden so closely
actually you can feel it
in the water
and there's nothing really can do at
that point you know it's you're waiting
out
i've always had a high respect and
appreciation for nature
there's days that it took me an hour
just to go half a mile
just seeing how quickly that river can
change not only from weather but you
know from currents you know so a new
appreciation for what that river itself
for what can come from what you'll face
in the mississippi
[Music]
you know it's so funny i get this
question all the time do you still
remember how it felt to ground
it was a crippling feeling i was
suffocating underwater now i've made it
my job to conquer my fear and to help to
get these kids swim lessons and learn
how to respect the water
my name is colin jones i was in the
olympics in 2008 and 2012 and i love to
give swim lessons cullen jones is a
four-time olympic medalist swimmer for
team usa
right after getting the gold medal in
2008 they put the drowning rates in
front of me
and i learned that 70 of african
americans nearly 60 of latin americans
nearly 40 percent of caucasians don't
notice him so it's a big problem all
over the u.s
i think the reason that you don't see as
many african americans in swimming is
because there's such a stigma that
black people don't swim and this is
something that needs to be broken
because we are losing children you're
losing adults and it's something that
can be changed by swim lessons
so when i want you guys to kick i want
you guys to wash your arms
swimming lessons are so important to
kids to me personally because i was
almost one of those kids and part of
this statistic
when cullen was just five years old he
almost drowned on a water slide at an
amusement park they had to come out and
grab me and resuscitate me because i was
underwater for about 30 seconds and
i think what's important about the story
is that i was fully supervised i mean it
was that easy and that quick for me to
go underwater that could have been my
last day on this earth
and with that near-death experience
cullen has made it his platform to bring
water safety education to kids from all
backgrounds
the way that i'm trying to change my
community is definitely with working
with the make splash initiative i knew
this is my way of giving back to a sport
that's given me so much
once you learn how to swim it's like
riding a bike you never forget
so take the time learn how to switch